first of all
just in case
uh people are not familiar with your
work
let's sort of linger on the big
bold statement here
which is the thing we see with our eyes
is not
some kind of limited window into reality
it is completely detached from reality
likely completely detached from reality
you're saying 100
likely
okay
so none of this is real
in the way we think is real in the way
we have this intuition there's um
like this table
is some kind of abstraction but
underneath it all there's atoms and
there's an entire century of physics
that describes the functioning of those
atoms and the quarks that make them up
there's
many nobel prizes
about particles and fields and all that
kind of stuff that
slowly builds up to something that's
perceivable to us both with our eyes
with our different senses as this
table
then there's also ideas of chemistry
that over layers of abstraction from dna
to embryos the cells
that make the human body
so all of that
is not real
it's a real experience and it's a real
adaptive set of
perceptions so it's an adaptive set of
perceptions
full stop
we want to think that perceptions are
real so so their perceptions are real as
perceptions right they are we are having
our perceptions
but we've assumed that there's uh a
pretty tight relationship between
our perceptions and reality if i look up
and see
the moon then there is something that uh
exists in space and time that
matches
what i perceive and
all i'm saying is that if you
take evolution by natural selection
seriously
then
that is precluded that
our perceptions are there they're there
to guide adaptive behavior
full stop they're not there to show you
the truth in fact the way i think about
it is they're there to hide the truth
because the truth is too complicated
it's just like if you're trying to you
know use your laptop to write an email
right what you're doing is toggling
voltages in the computer but good luck
trying to do it that way that's we the
reason why we have a user interface is
because we don't want to know that quote
unquote truth the diodes and resistors
all that that terrible hardware if you
had to know all that truth
it would your friends wouldn't hear from
you
so you
so what evolution gave us was
perceptions that guide adaptive behavior
and part of that process it turns out
means hiding the truth and giving you um
eye candy
so
what's the difference between hiding the
truth and forming abstractions
uh
layers upon layers of abstractions over
these over low level voltages and
transistors and
uh
chips and
uh programming languages from assembly
to python that then leads you to be able
to have an interface like chrome where
you open up another set of javascript
and html
programming languages that lead you to
have a graphical user interface on which
you can then send your friends an email
is that completely detached
from the zeros and ones
that are firing away inside the computer
it's not
of course when i talk about the user
interface on your desktop
um there's this whole
sophisticated
backstory to it right that that the
hardware and the software that's
allowing that to happen
evolution doesn't tell us the backstory
right so the theory of evolution is not
going to be adequate to tell you what is
that backstory it's going to say
that
whatever reality is and that's the
interesting thing it says whatever
reality is you don't see it
you see a user interface but it doesn't
tell you
what that user interface is how it's
built
right now we can we can try to look at
certain aspects of the interface but
already we're going to look at that and
go real okay before i would look at
neurons and i was assuming i was seeing
something that was
at least partially true
and now i'm realizing it it could be
like looking at the pixels on my desktop
or icons on my desktop and good luck you
know going from that to the data
structures and then the voltages and i
mean good luck
there's just no way so what's
interesting about this is that our
scientific theories
are
precise enough and rigorous enough to
tell us certain limits
but and even limits of the theories
themselves
but they're not
going to tell us what the next move is
and that's where scientific creativity
comes in
so the stuff that i'm saying here for
example
is not alien to physicists the
physicists are saying
precisely the same thing that space time
is doomed we've assumed that space time
is fundamental we've assumed that for
for several centuries and it's been very
useful so all the things that you were
mentioning the particles and all the
work that's been done that's all been
done in space time but now physicists
are saying space time is doomed there's
no such thing
as space time fundamentally
in the laws of physics
and
that comes actually out of
gravity together with quantum field
theory it just comes right out of it
it's it's it's a theorem of of those two
theories put together
but it doesn't tell you what's behind it
so the physicists are know that they're
their best theories einstein's gravity
and quantum field theory put together
entail that space-time cannot be
fundamental and therefore particles in
space-time cannot be fundamental
they're just irreducible representations
of the symmetries of space-time that's
what they are so we have so space-time
so we put the two together we put
together what the physicists are
discovering and we can talk about how
they do that and then we the new
discoveries from evolution of natural
selection both of these discoveries are
really in the last 20 years
and what both are saying is space time
has had a good ride
it's been very useful reductionism has
been useful but it's over and it's time
for us to go beyond when you say space
time is doomed is it the space is the is
the is it the time is it the very
hard-coded specification of four
dimensions
um
or are you specifically referring to the
kind of uh
perceptual domain that humans operate in
which is space-time you think like
there's a 3d um
like our world is three dimensional and
time progresses forward therefore three
dimensions plus one for d what uh what
what exactly do you mean by space time
what do you mean by space time is doomed
great great so this is by the way not my
quote this is from for example nema or
kanye hamed
at the institute for advanced study at
princeton ed whitten
also there
david gross
nobel prize winner so this is not just
something the cognitive scientists this
is what the physicists are saying yeah
the physicists are space-time uh
skeptics
we are they're saying that and i can say
exactly why
they think it's doomed but what they're
saying is that because your question was
what what aspect of space time what are
we talking about here it's both space
and time they're union into space time
as an einstein's theory that's doomed
and
they're they're basically saying that
even quantum theory this is with neymar
connie ahmed especially so the
hilbert spaces will not be fundamental
either so that that
the notion of hilbert space which is
really critical to
quantum field theory quantum information
theory uh that's not going to figure in
the fundamental
new laws of physics so what they're
looking for is some new mathematical
structures beyond space-time
beyond
you know einstein's four-dimensional
space-time or
supersymmetric version
geometric algebra signature two comma
four kind of there are different ways
that you can represent it but they're
finding new structures and then by the
way they're succeeding now they're
finding they found something called the
amplitude this is nema and his
colleagues the
the cosmological polytope these are so
there are these like
polytopes these polyhedra in in
multi-dimensions generalizations of
simplicities
that are coding
for
for example the scattering amplitudes of
processes in the large hadron collider
and other other colliders so they're
finding that if they let go space time
completely
they're finding new ways of computing
these scattering amplitudes that turn
literally billions of terms into one
term
when you do it in space and time because
it's the wrong framework it's it's it's
just a user interface from that's now
from the evolutionary point of view it's
just user interface it's not a deep
insight into the nature of reality so
it's missing deep symmetry something
called a dual conformal symmetry which
turns out to be true of the scattering
data but you can't see it in space-time
and it's making the comp the
computations way too complicated because
you're trying to compute all the loops
and feynman diagrams and all the feinman
integrals so see the feynman approach to
the scattering amplitudes is trying to
enforce two critical properties of
spacetime locality and unitarity
and so by when you enforce those you get
all these loops and multiple you know
different levels of loops and for each
of those you have to add new terms to
your computation but when you do it
outside of space time
you don't have the notion of unitarity
you don't have the notion of locality
you have something deeper and is
capturing some symmetries that are
actually true of the data
and but then when you look at the
geometry of the facets of these
polytopes
then certain of them will code for
unitarity and locality so it actually
comes out of the structure of these deep
polytubes so what we're finding is
there's this whole new world now
beyond space-time
that is making explicit symmetries that
are true of the data that cannot be seen
in space time
and that is turning the computations
from billions of terms to one or two or
a handful of terms so we're getting
insights into symmetries and we're and
all of a sudden the math is becoming
simple because we're not doing something
silly we're not adding up all these
loops in space time we're doing
something far deeper but they don't know
what this world is about all so
you know they're in an interesting
position
where we know that space-time is doomed
and not i should probably tell you why
it's doomed what they're saying about
why it's doomed but but they need a
flashlight to look beyond space-time
what is what flashlight are we going to
use to look into the dark beyond
space-time because einstein's theory and
quantum theory can't tell us what's
beyond them all they can do is tell us
that when you put us together space time
is doomed at 10 to the minus 33
centimeters 10 to the minus 43 seconds
beyond that
space time doesn't even make sense it
just has no operational definition
so but it doesn't tell you what's beyond
and so they're they're just looking for
deep structures like guessing
it's really fun so these really
brilliant guys
generic brilliant men and women who are
doing this work
uh physicists are making guesses about
these structures informed guesses
because they're trying to ask well okay
what deeper structure could give us the
stuff that we're seeing in space time
but without certain commitments that we
have to make in space time like locality
and so they make these brilliant guesses
and of course most of the time you're
going to be wrong but once you get one
or two that start to pay off and then
you get some lucky breaks so they got a
lucky break back in 1986.
a couple of mathematicians named park
and taylor
took the scattering amplitude for two
gluons coming in at high energy and four
gluons going out at low energy so that
kind of scattering thing so it's like
apparently for people who are into this
that's sort of something that happens so
often you need to be able to find it and
get rid of those because you already
know about that and you need to so you
needed to compute them it was billions
of terms and they couldn't do it even
for the supercomputers couldn't do that
for the many billions or millions of
times per second they needed to do it so
they they begged the experimentalists
begged the theorists and please can you
you got it and so park and taylor took
the billions of terms hundreds of pages
and
miraculous miraculously turned it into
nine
and then a little bit later they guessed
one term expression that turned out to
be equivalent so
billions of terms reduced to one
term the so-called famous park taylor
formula 1986 and that was like okay
where did that come from what this is a
pointer into a deep realm
beyond space and time but but no one i
mean what can you do with it and they
thought maybe it was a one-off but then
other formulas started coming up and
then eventually neymar connie hamad and
his team found this thing called the
amplitude which really sort of captures
the whole
a big part of the whole balox
i'm sure they would say no there's
plenty more to do so so i won't say they
did it all by any means they're looking
at the cosmological polytope as well so
what's remarkable to me
is that
two pillars of modern science
quantum field through with gravity
on the one hand
and evolution by natural selection on
the other
just in the last 20 years have very
clearly said
space time has had a good run
reductionism has been a fantastic
methodology so we had a great ontology
of space time a great methodology of
reductionism
now it's time for a new trick
but now you need to go deeper and and
show but by the way this doesn't mean we
throw away everything we've done not by
a long shot
every new idea that we come up with
beyond space time must project precisely
into space time and it better give us
back everything that we know and love in
space time or generalizations
or it's not going to be taken seriously
and it shouldn't be so so we have a
strong constraint on whatever we're
going to do beyond space time it needs
to project into space time and whatever
this deeper theory is it may not itself
have evolution by natural selection this
may not be part of this deeper realm but
when we take the whatever that thing is
beyond space-time and project it into
space-time it has to look like evolution
by natural selection or it's wrong
so so that's
so that's a strong constraint on this
work so even the evolution
by natural selection and
quantum field theory
could be interfaces into something that
that doesn't look anything like
like you mentioned i mean it's
interesting to think that evolution
might be
a very crappy interface into something
much deeper that's right they're both
telling us that the framework that
you've had can only go so far and it has
to stop and there's something beyond and
that framework the very framework that
is space and time itself now of course
evolution by natural selection is not
telling us about like einstein's
relativistic spaces that was another
question you asked a little bit earlier
it's telling us more about our
perceptual space and time
which um we have used as the basis for
creating first a newtonian space
versus time
as a mathematical extension of our
perceptions and then einstein then took
that and extended it even further so the
relationship between what evolution is
telling us what the physicists are
telling us is that in some sense the
newton and einstein
space time
are formulated
as sort of
rigorous extensions of our perceptual
space
making it mathematically rigorous and
laying out the symmetries that that they
find there so that's sort of the
relationship between them so it's the
perceptual space time that evolution is
telling us
is just a user interface effectively
and then the physicists are finding that
even the mathematical extension of that
into the einsteinian formulation
has to be as well
not the final story there's something
deeper
you